my name is Khalid ramadi I'm part of the
Innovation equity and future Prosperity
program at cfarm
cfar is just such a unique organization
I don't think there's many other
organizations that incorporate such
multi-disciplinarity into answering
really big picture questions to their
programs I think the other thing that's
really refreshing about cfar is that it
encourages sort of thinking outside the
box it encourages new collaborations
Beyond fields that otherwise we would be
exposed to I think one of the really
unusual things about cfar is not only
this broad array of disciplines that
they incorporate into different programs
but also that the fellows members in
each program are really geographically
diverse and I think this Global platform
is kind of a unique advantage that cfar
has over other research agencies I hope
that cfar can leverage some of the work
that comes out of these research
collaborations to One support our work
and amplify it and two that the work
stands to a bit of a testament on the
advantage of having such geographically
diverse multi-disciplinary programs that
cfart does